all right let's shift gears to a couple
of other teams who are making some news
on this third day of february the
washington football team
are they in the market for a quarterback
here is the new vp of football
operations with washington marty herne
the former panthers gm and also new
washington gm martin mayhew talking
about the team's quarterback position
we're certainly uh plan to look at that
position very uh very very thoroughly
and talk about it
yeah i mean i agree with martin you know
we were here basically two days and then
we went down and spent the whole week at
the senior bowl so
we're still getting our feet on the
ground but um obviously we're evaluating
you know all areas but
extremely impressed with the way um al
smith played last year the way taylor
heineck he came in the playoff game
um and uh we just got to go through the
process we uh have a lot of work to do
and we're just right now getting getting
comfortable with you know the entire
roster the most important thing i think
is to have somebody that's going to come
in and and be able to lead the team and
win games for you i don't know that
there is a line you know i think you you
want to be
uh you want to be smart but you want to
be aggressive in that process and uh
that's that's kind of what what our plan
is right now
i agree you want to be aggressive but
you do not want to mortgage the future
and again this is a team game i mean as
important as that quarterback position
is you have to have people around them
you have to have an offensive line to
protect them you have to have skill
players
i don't quite understand the structure
of the front office in washington it's
almost like their tv show co-host
shireen they've got perfect rhythm
and and uh symbiosis and uh they finish
each other's thoughts and
maybe they should have a show on peacock
maybe they should mike but it certainly
looks like that ron rivera is in charge
in washington is going to take over this
team and you know he was effusive in his
praise of alex smith all season and
immediately after the season not so much
today we didn't hear from ron rivera
there but he did speak today and he was
kind of lukewarm on on alex smith we
know they made an aggressive offer for
matthew stafford they wanted in on that
and now they've got to look forward and
figure out who their quarterback for
2021 is and ron rivera said today he
doesn't know who that quarterback of the
future is and of course we're all
linking cam newton kind of to them
because of his history with ron very in
carolina but mike i'm not so sure that
cam newton has a whole lot left judging
on what i saw this season
and just because cam newton and marty
herney and ron rivera were together for
an extended period of time in carolina
that doesn't mean all of them want
a reunion you know we we look for these
ways to connect dots and say well they
were together here they were together
there's a chance they don't like each
other i'm not saying for these three but
i'm just saying we have to factor in
that maybe
moving on
has allowed them to say that part of my
career is over and now we go in a
different direction
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports